ruling a kingdom is hard work and if you
don't know what you're doing your noble
crusade to unite the realms might end a
bit early here's some tips that will get
you started in the colorful world of
ninokuni - number one be well equipped
for most RPGs this goes without saying
however in ninokuni two weapons armors
and charms drop at a staggering rate and
because each party member can carry
three weapons at a time things can get
overwhelming fortunately the game
automatically sorts your best weapons
and armor to the top so every now and
then just hop in to the skills and
equipment screen and look for the ones
on HIGH easy number to manage your
metres during your battles you've
probably noticed the numbers on the left
of the screen
these are Xing gauges as you fight with
your equipped weapon this gauge will
build up and when it reaches a hundred
percent you can unleash a more powerful
version of a skill in order to get the
most out of the Zeen gauge I would
recommend using manual weapon switching
rather than automatic or semi-automatic
number three don't ignore side quests
and ninokuni - most side quests net you
more than just cash and experience some
of them allow you to recruit new
citizens for your expanding Kingdom
while building your castle may not have
any obvious benefits at the get-go it
becomes imperative later on if you see
this little human-like symbol next to a
quest it means you'll get a new citizen
upon completion you should make it a
point to complete as many of these
quests as you can also make sure to
revisit towns you've already been to to
see if new quests are available check
swift solutions regularly will come to
swift solutions if you are short a
citizen or need someone with a specific
skill head over to swift solutions you
should be able to find one of these guys
at every major city in the game
so if solutions allows you to take on
simple quests in exchange for tokens of
gratitude you can use these tokens to
recruit new citizens for your kingdom or
purchase rare items number five don't
ignore the tactic tweeker the tactic
Tweaker allows you to mess around with
some simple but powerful combat
parameters as you progress you'll learn
battle points which allow you to level
up these four sections
stro finna tease elements in ailments
spoils and arts of war
once you've leveled these up a few times
you can start playing with these
settings I would recommend investing in
spoils so you can adjust how much
experience and loot you get after a
battle
[Music]
but beware if you set it so you earn
more experienced enemies won't drop as
much money you can save yourself a lot
of grinding and resource gathering if
you tweak these settings early on the
arts of war setting also allows you to
boost the effectiveness of your dodge
and block which depending on what you're
up against
can save your skin number six upgrade
your spell's and higgledy z' unlike
weapons and armor you won't find new
spells in the wild instead you will need
to visit the evermore spell works here
you can level up your current spells and
learn new ones
unfortunately leveling up and unlocking
new spells will cost you money and
resources so choose wisely higgledy s on
the other hand can be found in the wild
hiding in stones like these if you have
the correct item you can lure them out
but if not you can brew new ones at the
hIgG Lurie you want to return to the
Hitler II often to nurture your higgledy
's they max out at level 10 and can
prove useful near the end of the game
number 7 check back often your Kingdom
will earn money and resources as you
play but your coffers can only hold so
much money coffer upgrades should be a
high priority but in order to maximize
your profit and resources you'll want to
return often to collect your kingly
taxes the same goes for research
projects in order for research projects
to take effect you must return to your
kingdom and hit complete research to
make the most of your time try to have
as many research projects going as
possible
although ninokuni isn't overly complex
there are a lot of systems at play here
and if you ignore one you could put
yourself at a considerable disadvantage
if you have any more tips drop them in
the comments below and if you have any
questions feel free to reach out to me
on Twitter thanks for watching
[Music]